well it's nine o'clock oh it is nine
o'clock and well he he does have until
901 doesn't he he has until 911 to
finish up that PP and get that cut that
mug
nothing nothing there's no drama that
was exactly what he's doing
oh man what's up boys hello fellas how
was your Thanksgiving man it was good
yeah I went to Denver and saw my sister
and uh and um her husband and their two
kids were very cute one and two my kids
are named one and two yeah wow it's one
of those simplifies it but in reverse
order where the older one is named two
and because they knew they were gonna
have another one oh that's so cool yeah
laughs
it's getting a couple jokes
just want to hear us talk about what
kind of turkey we ate or they was they
want some jokes right all right I don't
know maybe they do come on here go on go
on no it was it was awesome but it was
one of those typical thanksgivings where
like you know
it came in the house and and a child was
put into my arms like to take your
responsibility do this bye um and also
my nephew had hand foot and mouth
disease oh yeah oh sure now what is that
again I yeah it's like sores that are in
your mouth and on your hands and on your
feet and I immediately like looked it up
and it is contagious to adults but like
uh yeah no I don't I don't think I got I
caught it but
um but it's uh it's one of those
delightful things
now why is it that it's just the hand
the foot and the mouth yeah why those
things extremities all those are going
into the same that's what's going on
well they're little kid things so maybe
the foot's going in the in the mouth and
the hands going is it is it that literal
like is it because is it a bacteria is
it because the hands and the feet are
going in the mouth are we talking like
you know because babies do yeah
and there's nothing to do about it it's
just one of those things that just goes
away on its own and the kids get and
then they don't get again after they get
it oh it's like a chickenpox type that's
like one of those viruses that you can't
get again now what is that why are there
some viruses you can't get again and
other ones that you just get yeah but
they live with you yeah the the
chickenpox virus lives with you forever
yes it just stays inside priority of
like viruses or they're all hanging out
you know what I mean it's like are you
uh you repeater are you like a one-time
guy yeah yeah like seriously I go to the
hand I go to the foot I go to the mouth
you what I kind of show up in the hand
as you open the foot I show up in the
mouth I can't feel terrible uh I also go
to adults but yeah and herpes is like I
go to the mouth I go oh [ __ ]
big deal hey Kobe what's up new guy this
is so [ __ ] cool like a million people
of the [ __ ] creep I don't kill people
it's kind of interesting that some
diseases have names that are terrifying
and some diseases have names that don't
sound so bad like hand foot and mouth
disease just sounds sounds horrible it
sounds nasty it really does you know but
but something like
something like the bends which is not a
disease but something that happens to
you you hear like the bends that's nice
a little goofy feel a little bendy it
sounds like a dance craze or something
you know like
truly one of the most potentially
horrific ways to die now what is that
again that's where your blood you come
up too fast and so the the you get air
bubbles in your blood yeah is that right
actually I think it's nitrogen oh so
your body builds when you're when you're
under low pressure and so if you come up
too quickly it doesn't release and so I
believe that you have like too much
nitrogen where's it so early so we're
all breathing so we're all breathing
right now nitrogen but your body is
releasing it so when you go to what how
just through your skin okay so okay
through your yeah through your skin and
through and you're breathing it out and
whatnot but when you go hand on your
foot in your mouth when you go
underwater say you're scuba diving
you're still breathing in nitrogen
because you have the tank yeah but your
but because you're under such pressure
the nitrogen is not leaving your body
yeah and then when you come up it slowly
comes out so that's why you do safety
stops how does it get out through that
tight wetsuit
well water can water air model
everything's gonna get in and out of
tight
but if you come up too fast nitrogen all
tries to come out at the same time and
it can turn your [ __ ] blood to foam
yeah that's crazy what a funny thing to
be and it's called the bands human
beings being like I we've just
discovered a way that we can swim to the
bottom of the ocean awesome let's go do
it this is incredible we're like down
lower than we've ever been and we're
breathing under here we're so brilliant
the first shot I'll take it was up too
fast something's wrong it's even it's
even sadder than that that one of the
reasons one of the ways that it was
discovered the the whole idea of it was
when they were building the Brooklyn
Bridge and the guy and the the Builder
had figured out a way these poor guys
were going down into these caissons
which were pushed down deep underwater
and they had to walk up and down and up
and down and up and down and the Builder
was like I feel bad for these guys
they're putting in a long shift all day
long let me build them an elevator so he
built them an elevator and some of the
guys would still walk up and some of
them would would come up in the elevator
yeah but you feel fine at first and then
you're on your way home and you start to
like not feel so I think it depends if
you feel a little bendy they didn't know
what it was they couldn't they called it
caisson disease because they thought it
was something that you were getting and
they didn't realize until later that the
guys that were walking up were okay and
the guys that were taking the elevator
were
[Laughter]
by me John Bend
[Music]
um how are your thanksgivings guys
anybody got any good stories
um
that good huh I mean I saw Danny and Ria
oh yeah we popped over uh and saw them
and the kids and they're looking good
they're looking good Danny's looking
well John albo who's one of Danny's Pals
yeah John elbow right that looked
exactly the same look great is that the
guy with ponytail yeah John albo is is
uh is it inspiration for something is it
I'm going it's on go blow yeah there's a
lot of there's a lot there's a lot about
it yeah
not the name but the the character that
he did the way that Danny yeah played
presenting yeah okay yeah yeah although
yeah sure yeah it's like that Groovy 60s
thing yeah that's wild baby
you guys are still doing the thing man
that's so groovy man I dig that you know
I really did this wow man you can't swap
but
why did we ever move past that one I
don't know because the dog sounds cool
that's cool calling people cats that's
cool yeah same stuff's wild I like that
groovy and it's groovy like you know I
like that I like all that yeah like all
that language well we finished season
four so I thought this might be a good
time for us to watch some of your
bloopers from one through four
um the sunny bloopers I think are the
best that are out there
um I watch them all the time uh before I
came on the show and I still watch them
now
um uh they're amazing I have a theory
that it's maybe because your characters
are so awful to each other most of the
time so that when you break and you're
laughing with each other it's like the
biggest distance between the way you
were acting previously and right but you
get to see the real friendship
underneath the characters right yeah
um but I just love bloopers in general I
don't know you guys ever watch blooper
reels those shows actually we have a
tradition we didn't do it this year but
I think this is the first year in a
really long time that we didn't do it
and maybe we should well we're about to
well we are that's true do we do it at
this stage or do we do it right before
we go into scripts we do no we do it
right right before we even start the
room usually and my and that's what I
remember is that we so we we'll say what
it is but like we will often you know
especially in the it really started
happening in the later seasons of the
show when the three of us would get
together before we would sit down with
the room for the first day of writing or
breaking stories and we'd be like
oh boy you know this is kind of this
thing oh Jesus we got to do this again
you know how we're gonna do this and
then we would just sit and watch like a
season or two of bloopers to remind
ourselves of what we like about the show
oh that's sweet because it's good you
know it's a good way to kind of remember
like oh yeah when it's good it's good
like it's really fun like once once the
scripts are written and everything's you
know popping it's it's a lot of fun we
have fun so we have that great scenario
we're gonna have a lot of fun on set
yeah and uh and that's why we do it
really yeah
um what are your just off the top of
your head what are your favorite
bloopers from the show like what uh
Seasons or any from any season uh I can
tell you for for me the ones where I'm
La I know that I still continue to laugh
the hardest
um the one in the Dance dances their
asses off where we're eating chips yeah
I'm talking about cream for me I just I
just couldn't stop laughing on the day
and I it still makes me laugh I haven't
seen the bloopers from the um
from last season with Frank eating the
uh the the
meatball but that I know that that's
going to be funny yeah yeah I'm already
projecting a future where we have a
whole sequence in an episode that we're
breaking right now that we can't stop
laughing as we're talking about it in
the room we're going to talk about it
while we're writing it we're going to
talk about it why we're gonna we're
gonna be laughing hysterically when we
shoot it and it's going to be fantastic
and then there's going to be a ton of
stuff in the blooper reels yeah yes 100
that that's that's when when we hit on
something like that then I know that
we've really got something because well
I'm picturing that scene playing out and
we can't say what it is obviously but
it's gonna be yeah I'm superstitious I
don't even want to talk about it yeah
because then sometimes I feel like we're
like this is gonna be so funny and
they're like it's not that good yeah
something else winds up being but I have
a feeling yeah it should it should be it
should but then everyone will just
assume that that is that a different
scene is
yeah there you go the one that the one
that gets me every time in a major major
way
um
foreign
I can't even I can't even I'd laugh just
thinking about it it's I think it's for
yeah it's from the gang group dates and
Danny is like describing how in the 70s
he would go to all the orgies and they
were like
sounds like the 70s a bunch of people
would get together and the next thing
you know it was all hands and butts and
tits and
I could just slip right in there and out
nobody would know the difference it was
great
then AIDS ruined everything
laughs
the way the way he like drops and says
that like and I I mean I break the way I
break in in the blooper is exactly how I
break every single time I watch the
blooper of it that's it for me it's it's
so funny you and me and the police
station and I just I just can't keep a
straight face but snapped at it just
denying or getting it very specific
about the assault
he like bit your penis or something like
yeah he bit my dick oh he tried to he
tried to snap at it but it was fine and
he was like trying to snap at him
because my friend's not gay and he was
getting a [ __ ] from the guy he's like
I'm not gay another guy goes snapping at
him I go out yeah but but the good news
and then he shushed him but the good
news is sure
like c-mark she was raping you
yeah
yeah I guess so yes both of you no no
that'd be crazy not just my friend here
he got the worst I shook the guy off in
time no
so he was only raping you
you know what I think is really great
about that one too because it goes on
for potentially too long like there's
there's almost two men but we kept it in
there yeah we kept it in there because
it is funny but also like I think it's
fun for people to see like and it really
is true when there's a scene like that
in the show one of the things that's
really fun about doing the show is
every take is different
like you know what I mean it's not the
scene is scripted it's definitely
scripted but like you know you you find
these little Pathways these little
Alleyways to go down and you you hit on
different things and like if you watch
that every single one is is different I
mean they've got there are similarities
there but like
and that's what's so fun about doing the
show it's like finding those things and
each take every single take making it
different and you know finding new
things my favorite is the um
the one where Charlie says it's like I
don't even think he gets us man yeah
that was totally improved yeah it's not
scripted because you're the first one
the first one is yeah
did I get the line wrong and then you're
like then you gotta understand that and
then you watch you process that was the
very first scene we shot that season
wasn't it I think it was yeah it was the
first scene we shot and I think we might
even mention it in the blooper reel like
it's gonna be a long season or something
like that wait we did that that happened
before yeah the cat scene the the the
cat food scene like you need to stop
eating cat food it got cut from the
episode it got caught from the episode
it was just you guys coming over yes to
my apartment sitting you down and we
wanted to start with just a long time
you guys staring at me and me staring at
you and of course that was very
difficult for us to get through now my
brain is mush have we have we not looked
at the bloopers on the podcast we have
watched some of them how many Manhattans
did you have in Mexico did it mush your
brain up I drank tequila in Mexico
last night I had I I had a very big
Manhattan well I was watching the Eagles
game and it was awesome did they win
again they did they're on fire huh ten
and one ten and one wow that's a good
it's a good solid season for the
Philadelphia Eagles football yeah
football Thanksgiving football
Thanksgiving football man it's the best
I guess of all the things uh
Thanksgiving food wise
the stuffing I think is if someone makes
a good stuffing gravy on it yeah I love
stuffing I love mashed potatoes yeah
good but the stuffing stuff that's great
here's here's a question for you do you
guys eat one food at a time in other
words like do you take a bite
you know green beans or whatever and
like chew that up before you take a bite
of mashed potatoes or do you just get it
all in there like at the same time
it's outrageous you chew the green beans
and then you follow them back here and
then you get the potatoes and you follow
them up here somewhere no I mix them
together and then you get you get like
some steak and then once you get it all
chewed in there you swirl I mean turkey
you swirl it all around and then you
make yeah it's outrageous I put too much
it's I put too much food in my mouth you
know what it is because I do so I I do
the I so I I put I want everything in my
mouth at the same time okay cut that
uh no I like I want to take a bite of
turkey and I want there to be some gravy
on it but I also but then once I get the
turkey in my mouth I'm like oh you know
would go great with that would be some
stuffing so then I put a little stuffing
in my mouth right I'm like that's
[ __ ] great oh there's green bean
casserole that's gonna mix really nice
in there and then before I know it I'm
like yeah you know what I mean I'm like
it's disgusting that's what's good for
the sandwich the sandwiches that you can
have later yeah because you can put all
of it together on a Hawaiian sweet roll
or something like that oh I think what
is so funny about that is the amount of
thought you're putting into it
a little more lizard brain you know the
eating and it's just like trying to eat
now
your eyes Blaze whatever
there's not a lot of fun it's not a lot
of thought to just sounds like
yes but really all it is is this it's
it's
um
no I know but there's thoughts in
between those um
see I this is a listener for The
Listener at home
he was mining eating yeah I mean not
really but I wish reading as funny as as
David Hornsby you know we could we could
write in a thing for Cricket where he he
mime eats an entire Thanksgiving dinner
for yes
mine's a huge meal yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
tis the season to travel you know what
keeps happening to me when I travel
keep over packing you know I pack shorts
for you for running shorts for trainings
you know swim trunks for for swimming
joggers for yoga you're doing all those
things when when you're traveling uh
absolutely not no um but every time I
tell myself I'm going to before I know
I'm committed to the lie and the LIE is
eating up half my suitcase okay I got a
suitcase full of eyes okay well I think
you're in luck on all accounts because
fiori is designed for the gym but it's
also designed to look great outside the
gym and I can guarantee it's more comfy
and more better than whatever you're
wearing right now viori is an investment
in your happiness uh for listeners they
are offering 20 off your first purchase
so get yourself some of the most
comfortable and versatile clothing on
the planet at viore.com
Sunny pod that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny pod not only
will you receive that 20 off your first
purchase but you will enjoy free
shipping on any us orders over 75
dollars and free returns you just gotta
go to viori.com sunnypod and discover
the versatility of the Ori clothing
your balls and our friends at manscaped
are helping you clear your driveway for
safe travels that's right from from
stocking stuffers to white elephants
manscapes products
are at the top of every wish list grab a
body buffer for that holiday lover or
some a crop mops for your pops manscape
is a One-Stop shop to mop pop scrub and
why stop Atop The crop go beyond the
groin with manscape's full body product
line I'm a big fan of anything manscaped
a man's Stan if you will but I cannot
get enough of that body buffer finally a
product that lets me feel manly while I
lather my body and soap so go on help
all the men in your life go from Ice
Noggin to nice hogging this December and
save 20 off plus free shipping by going
to manscapes.com Sunny that's right 20
off plus free shipping by going to
manscape.com
Sunny manscape for a perfect gift that
will be the holidays biggest hit
why are they called bloopers because it
goes in between takes maybe yeah that
could be it awesome that's why I don't
think so no I don't think so either but
good theory thanks man that's fine
the word blooper was coined from the
word bloop which was a term used in
American radio in the 1920s to refer to
a terrible annoying feedback noise that
affected nearby radios when users turned
their sets and tuned their sets
incorrectly see it wasn't even cool so
today YouTube is Rife with blooper
videos so so a blooper as definition is
could you go back to that real quick is
a terrible annoying noise correct well
by the way available annoying feedback
noise I will say that like I do not I
I'm always amazed when people put
bloopers
at the end of a film or like they do the
bloopers from a show or whatever
and it's not funny at all it's just
people messing up yeah it's just like
somebody makes a mistake and then
everyone's like oh okay let's do that
one again and it's like that's not a
that's not a Looper dude that's well
that's annoying it's annoying it is it
is a blooper by the original definition
you're actually right I think the reason
why people seem to enjoy our bloopers is
because what you're saying before it's
alternate attempts at finding the joke
so so there's there's a surprise there
there's a surprise yeah if it's just
someone screwing up a line then it's yes
other people's bloopers messing up
messing up though maybe back in the day
would be more interesting because you
never got to see any outside material
right it was before certainly before
social media there wasn't direct access
to people you would just see them in
movies and TV shows you wouldn't see
even like making of or or uh the process
like to be there yeah
be in the movie being there at the end
of the movie they cut to Peter Sellers
doing uh he's laying on a able and he's
trying to sort of explain like who
mugged him and who he was supposed to
and it's multiple takes of him doing
this like 19 what year is that 1970
something yeah uh first example I can
think of a blooper reel at the end of a
movie and yet like a
a comedy movie but not yeah but not like
the kind of comedy movie that you would
expect bloopers to come after yeah there
are now I've seen compilations of like
classic
um Hollywood bloopers from like the 50s
and stuff
it's really weird um but it is a lot of
people just messing up and they're just
like oh darn it like they just but they
talk in that you know how like people
used to talk in that like mid-atlanta
yeah is that what Mid-Atlantic yeah it
is Mid-Atlantic yeah it seems very
British influence it's almost like
everyone that's why it's called
Mid-Atlantic
some tension here
okay
I'm enthused but if you could give us
some advice on how to handle a certain
situation then we promise we will come
back with our butts filled out so filled
so filled for you we need to [ __ ] that's
so filled for you
specific that is for you yeah now
filling our buttons now I know it's
coming and there's no way I can stop so
now Charlie's Charlie Charlie knows that
you know it's coming yeah
look at him he does he knows he's gonna
do it again situation I promise we will
come back with our butts
and I apologize because I'm messing it
up for you if you could just skip but I
miss those tattoos situation I promise
we will come back with our butts filled
oh like a Christmas stocking
[Music]
I had to get up nice to see Gregory
Scott Cummins laughing we should have
cut to him there why didn't we do that
in the blue room yeah maybe we didn't
have a camera back then uh
this is
hard to see Ryan smiling
operators like that's always fun when
the camera guys are laughing yeah this
is uh for our listeners of blooper where
the guys are massaging Charlie's
shoulders
um I love this uh because you guys
aren't even saying anything and yeah
he's groaning stop cracking yourself up
and it's because it was it was the
silence and the just the occasional like
um
and it's amazing like in the process of
making anything how many different lives
it takes and I'm sure that this was not
scripted I'm sure it was that we thought
oh you know it'd be funny let's start
the scene with just a slow long massage
yeah so that the audience doesn't know
exactly what's happening yet yeah yeah
what's going on and so it's extra funny
to us because it's new like we haven't
even really thought about it you know
like where was this basement was that
the herald exam yeah it was yeah yeah by
the way the number of times that the
basement has changed over the course
very different oh it's just yeah it's
like this is a completely different
[ __ ] basement yeah yeah what was the
you saw in the um the storm
it's nothing like that I don't know why
there's something about it being the
actual basement of the actual building
where the actual original bar set was
that like ties it together in my mind to
make you feel more legitimate but I'm
sure I don't know if it feels maybe just
because it's less of a by the way this
is set with one and two bloopers are
there any bloopers from season one in
here uh I don't know
having that much fun on set season one
but yeah we broke but I don't think it
was quite
the same Vibe though yes we'll see if
there are any from season one
how does this feel
hmm
that's good you want me to crack your
back
I'm gonna crack your back
oh come on that's disgusting yeah it is
stay away from that yeah it is
oh [ __ ] okay
what if we know how many scenes had
Danny done before this you know
a piece of food in his hair yeah yeah
yes it is and you better stay away from
stuff like that because there is no
future in it
there's no future in it
he's smelling her
my mouth
focus on your diaphragm
wait Charlie's real lady no I can't
believe that's all you know that's all
you know about diet she's pretty good at
it she's so good at it there she goes
she very rarely yes she's the toughest
she's tough hello American oh God this
you should be with me I believe in power
of good if you vote me the Democratic is
the right thing to do Philadelphia meets
your vote and so do
you at the end of it
so dude
it was funny that's what I feel like
that's one of our most popular bloopers
and yet I'll be totally honest I don't
think it's that funny you said that last
time but I don't know why just I think
yeah it's not the words it's the fact
that you're so irritated reading it yeah
that it's so stupid oh you're like I
cannot believe I'm reading this do you
want me to read it back to you right
right which by the way and again I think
we've talked about this but yeah that
wasn't in the script like I think the
scene cut before
yeah that was another example of the
props department just writing out some
things so that there looks like there's
writing on the paper yes and you
deciding to read it well and I and I I
read I I skipped words you know what I
mean like I purposely made it more
incomprehensible yeah so there's a scene
in there that we just watched with
Charlie and Dee
um that last week we were just
referencing because we were breaking
another story for this season just in
terms of process if this is interesting
to fans
um where Meg Rob Rozelle and I were
talking about a scene between Charlie
and d and we're like okay well what's
funny about it and then we reference
this up this episode and we were like
there's a few scenes over the years
where the two of them together trying to
figure out something and the process by
which they get there is the comedy of
the scene is what we're going for so we
like set up this template you know what
was that season two yeah and then we and
then we can return back to it and we see
that happen very often right yeah where
we set up a template and then we come
back to it for future episodes well
there's also really something really fun
for and it works with any Dynamic of
setting up that someone
is confident about
something that's stupid and wrong and
the other person yeah is irritated or
confused and explaining to them and it
works you know obviously great with
Dennis is upset that I'm I'm very
bullish about read the speech it's going
to work he's like you want me to read it
I'll read it and then that and like
that's why it's funny because of the
coffee he's getting it now you're
warming up too yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and then like same with like even
last season where you're explaining
you're irritated that you have to
explain Pittsburgh to me right like that
works but it works the other way too
with me being like
no dude I have a gun you have a ninja
sword and you're like you're like yeah
and you're like no but I can zigzaga I'm
like
and even though like I'm not like some
brilliant guy it's just I have some
mental advantage over the other
character and I think just watching that
Dynamic play out with someone so bullish
and confident about something that's so
clearly wrong to the audience yeah yeah
that the other person can kind of sit
back like the audience and be like no
that's wrong you know that it works like
every time it's the same when it's the
three of us across the desk from someone
that we're like we need a loan and this
is why it's gonna work and they're like
this is crazy and this is madness or
just trying to do something so simple
like create a dating profile the whole
the whole point of that what's funny
about that scene when you sit down and
break it from a story breaking
perspective you go well what's the story
beat here there really is no story beat
in there it's just creating a dating
profile for Charlie that's it that's it
there's not really a very strong
advancement of the narrative which is
generally a No-No in a in a scene
however we figured let's just give it a
shot and then the whole scene becomes
about the two of us simply a very simple
task set up a dating profile and then
the comedy comes from asking chart like
knowing that that's a very simple thing
to do we know what the right answers are
and now we're going to get Charlie's
answers and it's like jumping deeper
into character because you're trying to
understand Charlie better as an audience
member so I think I think right every
scene you want to reveal character right
you also want to push the action forward
you want to push the plot forward I
would argue that what we're actually
setting up there is how bad he's going
to be on that date you know what I mean
in a way we're setting up like who is
this guy under you know who is who is
this guy going to be on an actual date
right so then we start to hear these
answers and we're like you know so then
when we get to the actual date we're
like we already know it's not going to
go well we just don't know exactly
what's going to happen but there's a
little bit of dramatic irony there you
know
let's talk about your likes and dislikes
um how about your favorite food what
would that be oh milk steak
what milk stick
I'm not putting milk steak
milk steak she'll know what it is no she
won't know what it is Charlie nobody
knows what that is no okay all right
what's your favorite hobby uh magnets
okay making magnets collecting magnets
playing with magnets just magnets I'm
gonna put snowboarding we'll put
snowboarding I don't really snowboards
all right what if somebody likes uh
ghouls you know you guys have the
objective of getting me on board to try
this dating thing and then quickly
realize you're just gonna have to do it
yourselves and then you've set up that I
have bizarre interests that are gonna be
funny on a date yeah but then you've
also established that you have sort of
created the profile in which you say
that I'm a philanthropist which is all
leading towards me saying I'm a full-on
rapist
um which is all leading towards the date
going poorly yeah but but you're right
very little actually happens it's just
like but it's for sure it is
foreshadowing right so we're setting up
that your character what your character
is going to be like when the thing
actually happens but again it's the
dynamic of like you guys have a simple
task and I have a bizarre answer which
I'm confident on well and you're not
giving us the answer that we want but
you're giving the answer that's true
yeah
and it's also fun for the audience
sometimes you know that weird phenomenon
where you know what's going to happen
and that's fun because you're expecting
something and then and then you get a
specific that you weren't expecting and
that's what makes it funny but you're as
an audience member you're in on the joke
yeah it almost makes you feel closer to
the characters you're going you know if
you're sitting there with somebody who's
never seen Sunny before you it makes you
feel like I know this band
you know I've been around since the
beginning I know that Charlie is going
to say something funny here I just don't
know what it is you know what I mean
yeah the anticipation the anticipation
Joy yeah but it's not a total surprise
right no no no
there you are oh this is when she really
hit Tracy
you heard it too that it wasn't a rubber
she bonked it I saw Tracy's daughter
Polly at Danny's thing which I had not
seen since we did the tour which is 15
years ago yeah
here's a classic uh with the mcpoyle's
the sweat pattern on my shirt is bunk
yeah you know what I mean right let's
see what they're going for but it's just
a little overboard yeah we don't want
your lukewarm milk Liam and start
breaking bricks wet nips
I mean we had no idea he was going to
say that I mean that's start breaking
bricks wet the line will start breaking
bricks yeah and then he added he had a
wetness which is uh which is a classic
Jimmy yeah sorry Jimmy that's very Jimmy
we don't want your warm milk Liam it's
not making Rick sweat nips huh
a little nose flick today
actually Deandra I haven't even begun to
peek trust me when I peek
you'll feel it
uh
this weep okay so this was one of the
first like I feel like we really this is
the first time we really started to find
just how
you know Arch my character could be like
how far this is when we really started
pushing like leading into that sort of
like
villain talk yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and what and okay so look if
we're trying to break down what's funny
about it
Charlie when you're you're you're on his
side kind of where you you're like oh
[ __ ] how's this gonna go down and you
you you get it like you agree with him
that he's gonna Peak at some point yeah
it's going to be incredible and you're
also looking to see Dee's reaction yeah
because this isn't what you're what
you're what you're what we're witnessing
together is amazing yeah but it's also a
little bit like she thinks it's
ridiculous but he's on board yeah like a
child taking sides in a power Dynamic
being like um which which one of these
is going to so I I'm pretty sure that
it's this guy so I better jump on him
yeah yeah it's a very uncharly shirt do
you remember because
that's amazing he stole it yeah
yeah yeah
um
laughs
you've got to swear that you will not
tell anybody about this okay I swear
swear I swear
you're looking for a map in my mouth
pull them apart is it in the middle just
look
[Laughter]
I mean this is going to wind up giving
us indigestion but
you gotta eat yeah where'd you get food
it was down there
this is the first time Danny started
doing that start really improving really
dropping into like that
almost like barely a pulse kind of
casual
attitude which he does sometimes which
is so yeah so down there
you know passion
come on
who is that who was laughing okay so
that was definitely because he's moving
the camera but this is an example of
something that we knew in the room
was gonna be funny yep because we drew
it up on the board and we were like this
is going to be funny let's just do
anything and everything we can to make
sure that this scene happens that's it
the dick fire the dick flyer yeah but I
think whenever we came up with the
concept the inverted bicep yeah I mean
it was just like I think game over what
was different here was I think on the
day I improv that I knew yeah I think
yes
that I thought it was a day yeah yes
yeah you thought it was a date yeah
we all thought it was a bicep original
yeah yeah and then on the day I was like
wouldn't it be funny if I come to you
guys be like you knew it was Dick and I
thought that was cool yeah I thought
that's why we were doing it yeah but
there's a scene that before the stick
fire thing that's actually almost like
the opposite of what we were talking
about earlier which is all three of you
are writing this message that you're
putting on it and nobody is the straight
man like nobody's saying well this
sounds weird this thing that we're
writing and no one's disagreeing with
each other yeah really
everybody's fully on board with
something that and that works because
you know that the audience is looking at
it like this is [ __ ] ridiculous
audience so we just knew it was going to
be funnier if we were actually all on
the same page about it this is so great
but it's also like you said it's a setup
for something you know is going to pay
off later where you're listening to that
letter and you're like well this is
going to backfire
well sometimes it's just a gut feeling
too it's like it's you got to change it
up right because I think you're
expecting someone to be the straight man
in that scene and be like wait we can't
do that it's ridiculous like you know
what I mean and and so it's just you
know a constantly subverting
expectations is something I think it's
always really important to us in the
writing process of the show
you're the one that came up with the
bicycle I know I meant you started to
cut it like this and I thought it was a
dick and I was like well that's kind of
cool too because that's what's more
masculine
you know if you wanted to if you wanted
to be a bicep it should have more veins
in it yeah I know but what so that is
what that went into the show right and
we had to cut out immediately yes I
can't believe we made that into the show
yeah yeah yeah do you guys when you're
shooting do you try to if you're like on
the other side do you try to pause just
long enough before you laugh so that you
can use that like you're thinking about
that now and yeah yeah absolutely I I
sometimes I know it's it I know it's
coming I like there's and I know there's
no stopping it so the best you can do is
to just try and hold it for just one
second to give it I'll try everything to
keep the tank alive I'll look down I'll
turn around like yeah and we've used
that like when Glenn's like yelling at
the girls in the department store yeah
look at the store although everyone
watching it and who knows what it is
that's a great bar gonna be free drinks
for everybody so you know you'll come
you'll party with us and you can bring
your girlfriends too you know sure we
don't want just the two of you you gotta
bring your girlfriends that's a
requirement sounds like fun
can our boyfriends come too
your boyfriends
yeah our boyfriends
do you have boyfriends
I do not know
that the reason I invited you back to my
bar
to bang you
so funny but I think they enjoy it I see
a lot of people responding that way
about how much they love watching us
smile or laugh or try to try to hide it
it just shows we're having fun yeah it's
it's good for comedy because it it shows
that it's like this high wire act that
could fall apart at any moment and like
that's part of what's exciting to watch
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
supposedly it's the season of Joy but
the truth is we all feel down stressed
or a rage that knows no bounds this time
of year you know you can do you can go
ahead and get a special gift for the
person who matters most and that is
yourself one to lift your spirits and
not just until the eggnog wears off
having someone to talk to about how
you're feeling and what you can do about
it is truly a gift that keeps on giving
I've done better help in the past and I
found it super helpful to be able to
voice my thoughts to someone who is
licensed and knew who they're yeah
what's going on I don't know it's got
something about the way you read that
was so it was like a little bit like an
eighth grade report it was like super
cute I'm not an actor actually I know I
know but that's no I don't know it's
never hit it's never happened before
I've never cut it before but there was
this one little moment and then and then
and both Charlie and I heard it and then
we looked at each other and that was it
uh yeah I just left because they were
laughing yeah sorry
an ad blooper an ad blooper
um I've done better help in the past
wait you you have how'd it go for you
yeah I found it super helpful to be able
to voice my thoughts to someone who is
licensed and knew what they were talking
about as the world's largest therapy
service better help us match three
million people with professionally
licensed and vetted therapists 100
online plus it's affordable just fill
out a brief questionnaire to match with
a therapist if things aren't clicking
you can easily switch to a new therapist
anytime yeah no waiting rooms no traffic
no endless searching for the right
therapist yeah learn more and save 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
Sunny that's betterhelp h-e-l-p
dot com slash Sunny
[Music]
they say that every minute someone is
born someone dies someone's having sex
and someone is making their very first
sale with Shopify yeah I mean that does
make sense though Shopify makes it
easier than ever to start and grow your
business idea no matter what or where it
is has there ever been a better time to
get in the game and start that vintage
Jordan store I've always wanted to do
that to sell Jordans to clear out the
room of Jordans I have in my house
Caitlyn says they're they aren't a good
use of space or don't belong
in a grown man's closet I'm gonna start
with the Pippins and get to the Jordans
yeah we'll get rid of the pippets first
Jordans well you better go sell them on
Shopify before someone beats you to the
market bud sign up for a free trial at
shopify.com Sunny all lowercase go to
shopify.com Sunny to start selling
online today shopify.com sunny
we are supported by what do you do go to
the next one buddy yeah he's flying is
that because you've had your ag1 today
we are supported by athletic greens and
their five-star green powder ag1 now
what exactly qualifies as a five-star
powder well I feel like we should be
asking you right you're a five-star man
I am well all of us use ag1 every single
day so that must account for something
and check it out your body is absorbing
75 vitamins minerals Whole Foods Source
superfoods probiotics adaptogens with a
scoop okay now is that higher than the
herd what if I told you it was trusted
by Leading Health experts such as Tim
Ferriss and Michael Gervais and what if
I told you I don't know who those people
are
Ah that's fine that's fine I guess we'll
just have to rely on over seven thousand
five star reviews seven fat they have
seven
Charlie why didn't why didn't you lead
with that to make it easy athletic
Queens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com sunny
again that is athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
foreign
I see a door Mark private
is that the tour you're talking about
[Laughter]
this is a funny Exchange
smart man done man yeah yeah
is that the door you're talking about
what'd you say
you're the duster and all it all works
yeah with the epaulets
wow oh dude you think a pirate lives in
there
[Laughter]
such a stupid joke
it's so stupid Adam Stein I think was
that yeah yeah yeah
pirate private thing he was good for
like a yeah he was good he was good with
those little things like that Charlie
Kelly joke for sure yeah yeah you got to
leave so I can get
so oh yes so this is the scene where uh
you're talking to Wendell right so
somebody else had to so I think it was
me and you guys were just laughing at my
face at your face well you were laughing
at the whole yeah I was laughing at this
you're just breaking I was probably just
breaking and I'm like you can't be brave
you're not on camera like you're just
messing up I know I'm not even on camera
I'm already enjoying it too much yeah
yeah to be a functional stand-in for
your right for my window so then I when
I was behind the camera and then we just
switched yeah then yeah you're probably
at like uh you know you step in video
Village as they say okay
all right listen douchebag apparently
people think we look alike
Here Comes you you're looking at the
lines you're looking at the sides
all right listen douchebag apparently
people think we look alike I don't see
it
oh yeah yeah I stood out
I'm trying to do your voice I mean let's
reaction
genuine shock and surprise
this is great yeah just registering him
doing my an imitation okay now here we
go we have talked about this one
uh in what maybe one of the original
like the first few episodes of the
podcast we talked because I referenced
Nick grad so one of the executives at FX
lived in the neighborhood and decided to
stop by and see you know they very
rarely came to set um they just kind of
let us do our thing and they trusted
that we weren't wasting their money and
here we just spent like five hours on
this season but he but I kept looking
back and he was laughing so that was
always a good yeah but you shoot the
show so quickly that yeah yeah
you always stuck us to our schedule we
always made our news
5807. wow oh Jesus
dually yeah let's Call of Duty
foreign
[Laughter]
and we knew that the more excited we
were
yeah the funnier it would be that's our
crew our all of our crew is either dead
or in jail
College buddy of mine that's uh uh Mike
armor who went by Dooley who uh I wonder
if he's I had lost touch with him but I
wonder if we've seen this episode uh one
of the other things that's nice is the
flip phone that you always like flip it
down right before it just gives a little
you know something to it flip it closed
yeah he killed himself about two years
back
[Laughter]
I don't know why I don't know why I just
felt right he's dead yeah he awesome
I don't know I can feel your face so
close to mine yeah well that was funny
this is also something you you don't
it's a phenomenon that's strange when
you're watching it on TV it doesn't look
like we're standing that close to one
another it's a very normal to see on TV
but very rarely do you stand that close
to another human being yeah yeah it just
looks normal because you're so used to
it seeing it in films and television
it's also that you're facing forward and
you feel this man right here right next
to you looking right at you yes
and this place is actually pretty nice
oh yeah yeah no it's uh very Charming oh
yeah here you go this is this is just
that it doesn't break should we do that
again yeah this is the I still can't
wrap it around very uh yeah
this is the bouncy uh my face it's
bizarre Point look how hard
it's an unbreakable base dude
very uh I thought it was being cranked
[ __ ] you
I really did think I was like oh it's a
it's a prank and I was waiting for
somebody to be like yeah you we pranked
you or whatever and I was like are you
kidding me I really can't no this is
just the thing that I can't break
the clothes off goes off oh my God
this is when we found Frank
but like just the hair the big glasses
at the end how are you supposed to look
impossible impossible not to laugh at
that lady
he wants to be you getting banged by me
hey your apartment
[Music]
oh my God I know what it is
oh this is sick but I think he wants to
be you
having sex with me in my butt
yeah pencil going up the butt yeah
the pencil is new
now that's a body that just won't quit
he ain't gonna quit see I bet you if
you're popular you're gonna find a
sweaty hog that won't quit either
not scripted not scripted no what was in
the script like I bet you're gonna find
a bird oh I think it was a bird no I
don't even think that popping jeans off
yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it was just
it just he won't quit he won't quit but
calling it a sweaty hog yeah just
destroyed me I I I think there you're
supposed to jump to like now you quit
you're no longer legit yeah you're no
longer but you popped in the hog talk
which was good foreshadowing for where
your character's gonna go yeah sweaty
hog sweaty hog not before or after have
I ever heard it I've heard of Don
referred to as a sweaty hog and it's and
it's a shame because it it really has to
be more common
you don't have to be buried in a pot of
gold to get slushy
what well we're slashing prices Sulu you
won't need a pot of gold to get slushy
slushy
I've been married to this woman for 14
years now I've never heard her laugh
like that yeah that's not a way that she
normally agree because it's because
she's she's trying to she's starting by
trying to laugh in character but then
breaking transition it's like it's like
a it's like a combination of of crazy
Patty and Caitlyn
[Laughter]
it's only a matter of time because cream
always Rises to the top dude you have so
much cream inside you man and it's
always getting up in in Dennis's face
Dennis hates my friend he hates that
dude it's because he's like I'm all it's
all over it and he can smell it on him
and he drives him nuts
bro I gotta do man the eating the chips
enhances it yeah was this scripted the
cream conversation so part of it was so
Dennis hates my cream and then like you
can smell it oh no that was none and
then he gets into a thing where he say
you know that cream that cream beard
always that you're talking about yeah
yeah you know like I don't know why that
was so funny to me but something about
the chips made it funny too I
I remember getting like so sick from
those questions like I had to like lie
down yeah yeah you took a nap because
you couldn't get through the tank so you
just kept eating chips chips chips chips
chips and just yeah yeah awful yeah it
was a lot of chips
I actually remember we were in terms of
proximity we were
right behind that wall where you guys
were shooting because I remember very
distinctly being back there and laughing
my ass off behind the monitor
why don't you take that hot white cream
that's inside you
laughs
[Music]
get all that hot white cream
get it right up there
all right
all you gotta do is take those dance
moves man that cream that hot white
cream you're talking about
well that's all right we got
isn't making me sick
um all you got to do is take those dance
moves you know that cream that you're
talking about
bring it to the top
all you gotta do dude
hey man cream Rises to the Top This is
my favorite where you just start
laughing and for some reason
[Music]
but this is why we do it this is what
keeps me going this is what this is what
keeps me going this is what keeps me
coming back it's by the fact I keep
trying to leave
it's this man it's you know what I mean
like I missed that I I don't it's gonna
be that's why we do it that's why we do
it that's why that's why I do it I I I
do it because I it's it's just it it
really is an extension of of what I've
always loved which is you know being
together with your friends and making
your friends laugh like and having your
friends make you laugh and and
surprising each other and you know if it
weren't for that operation right like we
we have enough time filming wise the way
we light the show the way we shoot it
that we have room to do that and it's
not like we're burning through so we
keep the coverage simple so that we can
do take after take and find things and
find things and make each other laughing
it releases endorphins which makes you
happier plus that
you know yeah and how often in real life
do you get to laugh that hard
at your job on a daily basis at your job
or even in your personal life it's very
it's very rare so well it's very
appropriate then it's a blessing right
after Thanksgiving to feel gratitude for
the show feel gratitude for your friends
feel gratitude feel thankful yeah I'm
thankful
so very grateful very grateful for you
for you all for for making me laugh as
as hard as as I just was for the last 15
years
foreign